chers collègues nous recevons
aujourd'hui monsieur Grégoire COP en
tant ancien conseiller médias et
communication du secrétaire d'État
chargé des transports de la mairie de la
pêche Monsieur Alain vidalis et enfin
directeur de la communication de la
société uber France Monsieur Coop je
vous souhaite la bienvenue je vous
remercie vous êtes rendu disponible pour
répondre à vos questions vous le savez à
partir du 10 juillet 2022 plusieurs
membres du consortium international des
journalistes investigation on publie ce
qui est désormais convenu d'appeler les
uber files s'appuyant sur 124000
documents internes à l'entreprise
américaine d'été de 2013 à 2017 cette
enquête a des anciens lobbying agressif
de la société uber pour implanter en
France quand comme dans de nombreux pays
des véhicules transports et chauffeurs
des VTC dans concurrencé le secteur
traditionnel du transport public
particulier de personnes réservées
jusqu'à leur taxi dans ce contexte notre
commission d'enquête à deux objets d'une
part évalué l'ensemble des actions de
lobbying menées par uber pourra
s'implanter en France le rôle des
décideurs publics de l'époque et mettre
des recommandations concernant
l'encadrement des relations entre
décideurs publics et représentants
intérêt d'autre part ambition d'évaluer
les conséquences économiques sociales
environnementales le l'ubérisation le
développement du modèle Hubert en France
et les réponses apportées et à apporter
par les décideurs publics en la matière
votre audition s'inscrit plutôt dans le
cadre du premier objectif de notre
commission enquête puisque vous êtes à
la fois un témoin de l'action
gouvernementale dans le secteur du
transport public particulier de
personnes lors de l'émergence des
plateformes numériques tels que beurre
entre 2013 et 2015 ainsi qu'un acteur
majeur de la stratégie de Binger à
partir de juin 2015 lorsque vous
endossez la fonction de charger de
communication au sein de cette
entreprise qu'en 2017 d'une manière
générale ne souhaiterions connaître
votre appréciation des révélations des
uber-fice des critiques émises depuis le
début de nos travaux sur la stratégie
d'implantation de la CUV en France et
plus particulièrement sur sa stratégie
de lobbying auprès des acteurs publics
de façon
plus précise plusieurs questions nous
intéressent quel était votre rôle exact
au sein du cabinet du secrétaire d'État
chargé des transports monsieur vidalis
pendant la crise des taxis VTC avez-vous
tenté de faire valoir la position du
beurre et d'autres plateformes de VTC
auprès des ministres auprès des
principaux acteurs du gouvernement afin
de favoriser l'implantation du beurre
d'obtenir des modifications législatives
et réglementaires en leur faveur
avez-vous dans ce cadre obtenu des
modifications légitives réglementaires
qui vous paraissaient aller dans le sens
de l'intérêt du beurre et plus
généralement d'ailleurs des plateformes
VTC au moment de votre présence au sein
de l'entreprise
avez-vous par ailleurs été témoin
d'action de lobbying de la part des
représentants des sociétés taxis aussi
pour empêcher l'émergence des VTC je
note par exemple que vous avez souligné
les informations transmises en amont de
cette audition que Madame Vanessa
parodie ancienne conseillère
communication du ministre Michel Sapin
avait été recruté par les G7 en février
2016 comme chargé les affaires publiques
de la communication peu de temps après
votre départ chez uber est-ce que vous
en tirez des des conclusions
pouvez-vous nous décrire les raisons
pour lesquelles vous avez rejoint la
société uber en juin 2015 comme
directeur de la communication pour la
France
enfin dans les documents que vous nous
avez transmis votre courriel de départ
de la société uber mais en évidence le
fait que vous n'auriez pas toujours été
d'accord avec Pierre Dimitri gorcoty et
Thibault Saint-Fal je cite merci Pierre
Dimitri et Thibault de m'avoir recruté
malgré divergences de vue et que la voix
et permis de vivre tendeur de débats
parfois quasiment philosophique
pouvez-vous nous expliquer en quoi
consister ces divergences nous aurons
bien sûr d'autres questions mais je vous
propose d'entamer une discussion à ce
stade je rappelle que cette audition est
ouverte à la presse qu'elle est
retransmise en direct sur le site de
l'Assemblée nationale et avant de vous
laisser la parole je vous rappelle que
l'article 6 de l'ordonnance du 17
novembre 1958 relative au fonctionnement
des assemblées parlementaires un pose
aux personnes auditionnées par une
commission d'enquête de prêter serment
de dire la vérité toute la vérité rien
que la vérité je vais donc vous inviter
monsieur COP à activer votre micro levez
la main droite et dire je le jure je le
jure merci je vous laisse la parole
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés c'est l'occasion pour moi de
revenir sur un temps désormais assez
ancien il a près de 10 ans sur les deux
années que j'ai passé à travailler chez
uber alors en pleine expansion vous le
savez et cela vous a été confirmé par
l'individus lui-même la semaine dernière
je n'ai jamais eu à traiter du sujet
uber lors des fonctions ministériales
auprès de lui d'abord au ministère
chargé des relations avec le Parlement
pendant deux ans entre mai 2012 et avril
2014 puis au ministère des Transports de
la mer et de la pêche en septembre entre
septembre 2014 et juin 2015 j'étais son
conseiller en communication chargé du
lien avec les médias je n'intervenais
pas sur le fond des dossiers qui étaient
portés par les conseillers techniques et
surtout à l'invitalis en tant que
ministre des Transports n'étaient même
pas en charge du secteur d'activité
c'est à l'époque puisqu'il est devenu
par la suite mais c'est d'ailleurs
peut-être même une anomalie que le
ministère de transport ne soit pas
chargé ce secteur mais quand je
l'accompagnais il n'avait pas la
compétence sur ce domaine
j'imagine donc si vous avez souhaité
m'entendre aujourd'hui c'est parce que
vous demandez pourquoi et d'ailleurs on
me l'a demandé pourquoi ce choix de uber
pour comprendre ce qui m'a amené à faire
ce choix et la façon dont j'ai vécu ces
deux années il faut savoir qu'elle a été
mon parcours je me permettrais donc de
commencer par me présenter brièvement
j'ai étudié le droit économique et
européen à l'Université de Strasbourg et
à son copain Paris avant d'obtenir le
certificat d'aptitude à la profession
d'avocat en 2011 j'ai ensuite choisi de
rejoindre l'association de consommateurs
UFC Que Choisir en tant que juriste
lobbiste chargé des questions de droit
de la concurrence et de nouvelles
technologies justement ça a été
d'ailleurs au passage ma seule
expérience de ma vie en tant que
lobbyiste chez FC que choisir et à
l'époque tout le monde me félicitait
d'être l'obéiste parce que le Boeing est
quelque chose pour moi qui est neutre ça
dépend de quels sont les intérêts que
vous représentez mais on fait souvent un
faux procès et certaines personnes
tentent de mettre ce mot de manière
caricaturée mais s'il n'y a pas de
lobbying c'est-à-dire de représentation
d'intérêt il n'aurait pas de démocratie
et donc quand on est de lobbyiste chez
FC que choisir ce que j'étais à l'époque
tout le monde était très content que je
fasse le travail et c'est la façon la
seule personne la seule moment de ma vie
où j'ai fait ce métier
j'ai ensuite rejoint le cabinet
d'invitalis lorsqu'il a été nommé
ministre des Relations avec le Parlement
en mai 2012 en tant que contractuel
n'étant pas fonctionnaire ce statut est
extrêmement précaire vous ne savez ni
quand vous commencez ni quand vous allez
arrêter et cette expérience est
brutalement arrêter lorsque Jean-Marc
airot a quitté ses fonctions de Premier
ministre au printemps 2014 je me suis
alors retrouvé au chômage comme tout
contractuel avant de rejoindre l'agence
de communication TB1 corporate
pendant quelques mois puisque dès la fin
de l'été 2014 à l'invitalis a été
renommée ministre cette fois chargé des
transports de la mer et de la pêche et
il m'a proposé de poursuivre mon travail
à ses côtés ce que j'ai accepté et ça
date donc intervient un hasard de
l'histoire mon ancien supérieur au sein
de l'agence de communication où j'étais
pas en 4 mois
a pris le poste nouvellement créé de
directeur de la communication du beurre
pour l'Europe de l'Ouest nous nous
entendions bien on essaie en contact on
avait déjà travaillé ensemble du coup
ils connaissait ma façon de travailler
et mes convictions ça lui semble de
lutter contre les monopoles et casser
les rentes qui avait déjà guidé mon
choix d'aller travailler chez de choisir
il m'a ainsi expliqué que lui dans sa
mission était de structurer une équipe
et notamment de recruter assez urgemment
un directeur de la communication pour la
France il s'est dit que ça pouvait
m'intéresser il m'a parlé de ce poste
après quelques semaines de réflexion
j'ai alors décidé d'accepter d'entrer
dans le process de recrutement en me
disant que tu étais toujours intéressant
de comprendre comment ces entreprises
américaines c'est l'émergence des gafams
à l'époque recrutait et de vivre ce
process de recrutement et de voir ce que
ça allait donner je t'ai pas forcément
partiellement convaincu de l'ensemble
des mérites du beurre il fallait
disrupter ce marché j'avais des
questions je suis rentré dans ce process
de recrutement qui est particulièrement
difficile et sélectif c'est une
expérience intéressante à vivre et il
s'avère que j'ai été retenu mon proposé
de les rejoindre et j'ai donc rejoint
über en juin 2015 en plein milieu de la
crise du burpe après évidemment avoir
saisi la commission de déontologie
puisque j'étais en cabinet ministériel
qui a rendu un allu favorable et je vous
ai donné tous les éléments qui étaient
liés à la fois à cet avis aux
discussions qui a pu avoir en amont où
ils m'ont demandé de préciser justement
ce que je faisais avant et après
au bout de deux ans donc en juillet 2017
j'ai quitté
uber j'ai démissionné du beurre et j'ai
rejoint au vhcloud qui devenait de
devenir la deuxième licorne française
donc ces entreprises technologiques
valorisées plus d'un milliard d'euros et
j'ai rejoint comme conseiller de son
président fondateur au taf là-bas
j'étais donc un des premiers chiffres
staff comme on dit dans la technologie
française cette fonction que vous
connaissez bien ici puisque c'est au
confins des rôles de directeur de
cabinet et de chef de cabinet j'y suis
resté deux ans et demi puis j'ai
effectué un passage à l'Olympique de
Marseille en tant que directeur de la
communication et de l'impact sociétal
pendant la crise sanitaire du covid et
depuis un peu plus de deux ans j'ai créé
ma propre entreprise de conseil GRK
qu'est-ce que c'est GRK nous conseillons
des dirigeants et des personnalités sur
leur stratégie leur organisation leur
communication et leur impact sociétal
par exemple on a récemment accompagné la
sortie du livre les fossoyeurs sur ORPEA
vous avez entendu parler pour lequel on
avait construit une stratégie
d'influence globale permettant de
mobiliser en amont pendant et après la
sortie du livre tout un ensemble de
parties prenantes concernés par le sujet
des EHPAD
tout en déployant un plan de
communication bien rodé et en préparant
le journaliste Victor Castanet autour du
livre le plus efficacement possible pour
qu'il puisse être dans les différents
médias et être pertinents à côté de ça
on accompagne les dirigeants de
nombreuses startups qui font bouger les
lignes qui croisent rapidement et qui
font bouger les choses pour revenir à
uber l'ensemble des analyses que je peux
vous exposer aujourd'hui résulte de ce
que j'ai peu à peu compris quand j'y
travaillais c'est pour ces deux années
et après on continue de travailler dans
la technologie
c'est le contexte de l'époque doit être
appelé aussi les différentes auditions
l'ont dit mais il y avait les attentats
à ce moment là donc quand on contexte
sécuritaire très sérieux il y avait une
volonté politique de faire baisser le
chômage et on entendait chaque mois la
courbe du chômage avec impatience et le
secteur de taxi lui proposait un niveau
de qualité de service assez incertain il
était très peu digitalisé et il manquait
beaucoup de taxis notamment à Paris les
nouvelles technologies ont permis un
foisonnement l'écosystème VTC donc il y
a évidemment uber mais aux Etats-Unis
c'était lift le grand concurrent il y a
des concurrents locaux partout dans le
monde et en France il y avait le
chauffeur privé le CAB Marcel snapcar
Allocab et même hitch que départ était
concurrents du bord pop avant de
maintenant devenir une plateforme de VTC
à l'époque uber c'est quoi
uber c'est en quelque sorte un objet
économique non identifié on est au
milieu des années 2010 et uber incarne
le début d'un cycle de levée de fond
géant qui accompagne le développement de
technologie mondialisée il y a une
technologie qui émerge cette technologie
on peut essayer de la répandre partout
dans le monde au même moment en tout cas
c'est l'idée qui se propage à cette
époque là personne ne sait comment ces
entreprises vont se développer vont
fonctionner elles-mêmes ne le savent pas
vraiment et uber particulièrement c'est
le premier choc physique du numérique
c'est pas seulement des services
virtuels comme un moteur de recherche ou
un réseau social avec uber la
technologie impacter le monde réel dans
nos rues concrètement et en France en
2009 le Parlement avait créé le
dispositif des VTC qui est un des trucs
qui existait déjà sauf qu'en parallèle
l'iPhone est arrivé l'iPhone c'est des
applications et la géolocalisation et
donc c'est le choc de ces deux moments
la création d'un régime qui permettait
une activité et cet outil technologique
qui était nouveau qui n'avait pas été
anticipé évidemment qui a fait quand
sort en sorte que ça se développe et la
France est devenue un pays très
important pour über assez rapidement
à mon arrivée chez uber donc quand
j'arrive en 2015 le poste lié aux
affaires publiques était d'ores et déjà
pris en charge par une autre personne
Alexandre Quentin kegre qui travaillait
sous l'autorité de Mark Magan moi en
tant que directeur de la communication
ma mission c'était de mener là bataille
d'influences communicationnelles en
coordonnant la communication du beurre
en France donc d'assurer quoi les
relations avec les médias nationaux et
locaux de très rapidement je suis devenu
porte-parole de l'entreprise donc de
prendre la parole dans des colloques
dans des conférences à différents
endroits aussi d'accompagner les équipes
marketing qui elles faisaient la
communication en termes de publicité
pour inciter des passagers à utiliser
l'application et les aider à faire en
sorte qu'il ne commettent pas de faux
pas parce que quelque temps précédemment
il y a eu quelques faux pas marketing
qui a été fait et puis d'être en
coordination constante avec les équipes
globalisées du beurre parce que on était
partout dans le monde au même moment
c'était une petite équipe à ce moment-là
et il fallait chaque incident n'importe
où dans le monde était repris dans les
autres pays donc en fait on travaillait
7 jours sur 7 24 heures sur 24 pour être
sur le qui-vive parce que on va essayer
de comprendre ce qui se passe et on
avait des journalistes qui nous
appelaient toute la journée au début
j'étais seul à assumer ses fonctions que
c'était une création de poste de
directeur de la communication en France
et puis j'ai assez rapidement pu
recruter deux personnes qui m'ont aidé
sur la communication qu'on appelle
corporate à destination du grand public
et la communication compte summer à
destination des consommateurs
pour résumer après une discussion je
réponds à vos questions mais pour moi il
y avait une certaine grande immaturité
du beurre à tout point de vue
à la fois en termes de business et la
faire publique pourquoi parce que la
logique des immenses levées de fonds qui
étaient la mode à cette époque on en a
un peu revenu impose un retour sur
investissement assez rapide et donc un
modèle de développement très rapide et
quand on va très vite c'est pas
forcément viable à long terme et ça
porte de nombreuses contradictions
la question qu'il faut toujours se poser
c'est ce n'est pas parce qu'une
innovation et technologiquement possible
qu'elle est socialement souhaitable et
si elle peut être en partie
sociétalement souhaitable là je pense
que personne peut être le fait de
digitaliser le secteur des taxis mais il
faut réfléchir à comment on accompagne
ça en termes de protection sociale
idoine et c'est un peu le débat que vous
avez vu ce matin avec cette potentiel
troisième voie et que les différents
ministres aujourd'hui le être
indépendant offre beaucoup de liberté et
il y a beaucoup de secteurs où les gens
sont vraiment contents d'être
indépendants et vont même gagner plus
d'argent et vivre mieux que quand ils
étaient salariés et il y a d'autres
secteurs ou potentiellement les
indépendants peuvent effectivement être
appeler le four indépendant je sais pas
vraiment ce que ça veut dire mais en
tout cas il y a besoin de vous de vrais
protection donc la question pour moi
elle est plutôt là un dernier point sur
uber cette logique financière des
grosses levées de fonds amène pour
certains une envie un besoin d'entrer en
bourse assez rapidement et quand il
s'agit d'entrer en bourse chez uber il y
avait une ambition une perspective qui a
été portée de faire la plus grande
introduction en Bourse dans le monde
c'est à dire une introduction à plus de
100 milliards de dollars en moins de 10
ans et pour certains salariés du beurre
pour qu'ils étaient un vrai objectif ça
amenait à prendre des décisions à court
terme et ces décisions à court terme
sont pas forcément les bonnes pour finir
ce propos illuminaire je reviendrai sur
un mot le mot ubérisation qui un des
angles d'études de votre commission
d'enquête c'est en mai 2016 que pour la
première fois le mot uberisé rentrer
dans le dictionnaire dans le petit
Robert et à l'époque la définition
c'était quoi c'était
déstabilisé et transformé avec un modèle
économique innovant tirant parti des
nouvelles technologies
c'était une définition qui était neutre
et ça correspond bien à l'état d'esprit
de l'époque
on sait pas on ne savait pas encore
quels étaient des conséquences de ce
changement de paradigme et l'entrée la
technologie aujourd'hui forcer le
constater le terme est connoté
négativement pour moi ça montre bien que
les précipitations du début des années
uber ont finalement été préjudiciables à
uber et s'il fallait assurément mettre
un pied dans la porte pour faire bouger
les lignes d'un secteur du transport à
la demande qui était trop sclérosé et
qui dysfonctionnait un peu partout dans
le monde l'immaturité du beurre et la
vitesse de son déploiement lui ont été
pour moi préjudiciable
merci Monsieur monsieur cops très
intéressant est-ce que je voudrais
revenir donc un peu sur la période ce
qui était intéressant quand on a
auditionné Mark Magan notamment c'est
qu'il est revenu dans le détail sur les
actions de lobbying et vous l'avez
souligné non seulement auprès des
acteurs publics mais aussi l'influence
l'environnement intellectuelle culturel
médiatique grand public qui en plus
était déjà relativement favorable à uber
puisqu'il a porté une nouvelle offre un
nouveau service innovant face à
l'insuffisance de l'offre de taxi à
l'époque
mais finalement monsieur Magan après
nous avoir parlé de tous les moyens qui
avait été
déployés pour faire ce lobbying nous a
dit qu'il en tout cas les responsables
du beurre de l'époque avaient le
sentiment
que ce renforcer que réguler qu'encadré
la loi était venue à la loi ganguillaume
les lois Macron el khomri n’important
aucune modification en faveur ou contre
derrière les VTC à ce moment-là c'est la
période où vous étiez aussi alors sur la
partie communication j'en conviens mais
est-ce que c'est soit votre sentiment en
tout cas le sentiment qui vous
paraissait partager que vous parliez à
Monsieur gorcottier ou monsieur saint
Phal par exemple est-ce qu'en 2017 au
moins vous quittez 2017 si j'ai pas de
bêtise quitter l'entreprise est-ce que
vous allez sentiment que l'entreprise a
l'impression d'avoir gagné son combat et
son lobbying ou au contraire être assez
déçu comme nous l'avait indiqué Marc
Magan par les les différentes
dispositions qu'on peut être prises au
cours des années précédentes
très déçu même il suffit de regarder
l'état des faits et derrière c'est ce
que vous avez été dit dans 4 de cette
commission d'enquête toutes les lois qui
se sont succédées les décrets les
mesures sont les dents à l'inverse et à
l'encontre d'un développement serein et
pérenne du beurre et on peut réfléchir
c'était normal pas normal mais ce qui
est sûr que dans cette philosophie c'est
à nouveau ce qu'il faut comprendre cette
philosophie qui vient la Silicon Valley
de Jean de la technologie ce sont des
gens qui sont extrêmement rationnels
c'est des gens pour qui il y a une
technologie qui permet d'apporter un
meilleur service du côté de l'usager du
consommateur il faut pouvoir lui donner
c'est aberrant d'être dans Paris ne pas
pouvoir trouver taxi donc on va pouvoir
le faire et dans cette logique était
extrêmement simple la technologie arrive
on doit pouvoir la porter tout de suite
certainement trop vite il y avait une
vraie incompréhension du mode de
fonctionnement politique c'est des gens
qui pensent c'est possible on doit faire
un claquement de doigts et demain ça y
est c'est là non la société prend du
temps les évolutions prennent du temps
il faut accompagner ces changements et
il y avait une immaturité totale sur
l'accompagnement du changement donc
la réalité c'est pour moi mes collègues
des affaires publiques étaient au
contact des politiques au quotidien
parce que j'étais pas ils étaient des
effets c'est une mission impossible on
leur demandait en interne de faire des
choses qui pouvaient pas réaliser ce qui
a amené et souvent ça a été un sujet de
discorde entre nous moi je trouve qu'ils
ont rajouté dans la meilleure dont ils
arrivaient à mettre en avant certaines
choses qui arrivent à faire et je disais
même à l'époque c'est une phrase que je
dis plusieurs fois et j'ai employé
parfois même auprès de deux journalistes
à qui discutaient en off il faisait des
forêts avec des brins d'herbe et puisque
j'avais une compréhension de comment ça
se passait en politique quand je les
voyais à raconter ce qu'il faisait et
raconter la manière qu'il le racontait
notamment dans le compte rendu du coup
écrit qui sont retrouvés dans le
liberfiles ça correspondait pas à la
réalité moi c'était vraiment des choses
qui étaient des exagérations et pourquoi
parce qu'ils étaient sous pression et
donc ça revient à l'audition de Marc
Magan il arrive devant vous en disant
j'ai été le lanceur d'alerte des
hubert-fibes j'ai apporté plein de
documents sur le fait qu'on a fait un
énorme lobbying partout dans le monde ah
mais à la fin mais ça a pas marché du
tout bah oui donc du coup ce super
pouvoir de lobbying de boîte qui arrive
avec plein d'argent qui arrive à
transformer la loi c'est juste pas vrai
en fait c'était une chimère qu'ils ont
cru pouvoir faire parce qu'ils pensent
donc penser que l'argent arrive étant de
faire plein de choses mais c'est pas
vrai madame la rapporteur vous avez cité
souvent Maxime Bruno c'est une Drino
vous avez vu l'âge qu'il a l'âge qu'il
avait à l'époque en 2014 quand il écrit
ce fameux email quand c'est un des
premiers à sortir maintenant avec Manuel
Macron il est sorti d'école 3 ans
auparavant c'est pas un lobbyiste
chevronné extrêmement diplômé c'est
quelqu'un qui est très très jeune et en
fait cette boîte c'est une boîte de gens
jeunes qui sont avec beaucoup de naïveté
de crédulité qui ont pensé que et par
des vrais convictions que transformer ce
transport à la demande que d'apporter la
technologie c'était bien et du coup ils
sont heurtés à un mur et c'est ce qui
s'est passé en termes de lobbying pour
moi ils ont malheureusement dû exagérer
des choses
vous dites en fait il y a un mélange à
la fois de naïveté peut-être eux dans
leurs échanges avec les pouvoirs publics
à penser qu'après juste un entretien ça
y est on a une avancée
historique et d'exagération en interne
pour plaire soit peut-être au management
en France ou au management en Californie
aussi on a pu entendre qu'il y avait
parfois de la la pression et d'ailleurs
c'est ça a été rapporté publiquement etc
de la part de
du du Travis scalanique et de son
entourage ça c'est c'est intéressant
mais alors pour revenir donc sur ce que
vous dites soyez des accords presque
philosophiques ou les conversations
philosophiques sur quoi est-ce qu'il
portait quelle relation vous vous aviez
avec à ce moment-là monsieur gorcoty par
exemple et pourquoi et d'ailleurs
qu'est-ce qui explique votre départ de
l'entreprise
quand je suis arrivé en 2015 Dimitri
pierre Dimitri venait de prendre le
poste de général manager c'est comme ça
que ça s'appelle pour l'Europe de
l'Ouest donc il s'occupait plus de la
France des Thibault saint Phal qui était
là moi j'ai échangé régulièrement que
Pierre Dimitri mais le plus souvent est
au quotidien c'était avec Thibault sans
fan ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
chez uber les équipes communication à
faire public était une équipe distincte
qui avait été créée justement avec
l'arrivée de Mark Magan au début mais on
administrativement hiérarchiquement on
ne répondait pas des directeurs locaux
Thibault saint Phal en France n'était
pas mon patron je répondais d'une
hiérarchique différente qui était
directement rattaché aux États-Unis donc
en termes de pression oui effectivement
nous on devait à la fois collaborer au
quotidien avec des opérationnels qui eux
un objectif qui était très concret
développé le business donc avoir plus de
passagers et avoir plus de chauffeurs et
quand on arrive nous quand cette équipe
est créée pourquoi elle est créée elle
est créée parce que en 2012 ou 13 aux
Etats-Unis c'est le conseil spécial de
Barack Obama David Clov qui est recruté
et donc lui théorise ce que fait
politiquement uber politiquement
uber fait quoi un C2 démocratiser le
transport à la demande grâce à la
technologie en complément et transports
en commun et donc ça il arrive le
terrorisme sauf que pour pouvoir
l'expliquer les opérationnels qui eux
dans le quotidien ont pas le temps le
conceptualiser et font des erreurs des
raps un peu dans tous les sens parce que
eux pour eux la fin justifie les moyens
presque et donc là on arrive à un moment
on décide il décide de créer une
hiérarchie différente communication et à
faire publique et là il recrute une dame
qui s'appelle Rachel Weston qui était
l'ancienne patronne de la gomme et des
affaires publiques de Google et qui est
l'arrivée quasiment en même temps que
moi pour recruter dans chaque pays un
directeur de la com et un directeur des
affaires publiques créer une équipe
mondiale et que ces équipes mondial en
fait travaille
pas contrôler mais accompagner le
développement opérationnel en gros on
était en train d'en permanence de dire
attention ça ça va pas ça ça va bien et
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire qu'au
quotidien les opérationnels nous
voyaient pas forcément d'abonnement œil
nous il y avait des vrais combats au
quotidien dans cette entreprise ça peut
paraître bizarre à expliquer parce qu'on
a la logique d'entreprise en place avec
un modèle très traditionnel mais chez
uber dans une boîte aussi jeune qui veut
être partout dans le monde aussi peu de
temps on a beaucoup d'autonomie et de
responsabilité et si on a recruté c'est
pour notre mot à dire et donc dans les
discussions internes c'était des vrais
combats j'avais foi l'impression de me
battre autant si ce n'est plus en
interne qu'en externe ou pourtant
j'étais le porte-parole du beurre à être
sous le jeu de toutes les questions et
c'était un combat en permanence mais on
le faisait tous pourquoi parce qu'on
voulait tirer cette entreprise qui
allait très vite dans le meilleur sens
possible et donc ça a été des
discussions mais sur plein de sujets en
permanence ou est-ce qu'on doit plutôt
faire comme ça comme ça pour moi il
était évident par exemple que la
question de la protection sociale
c'était pas une option en fait c'était
quelque chose aussi un chauffeur de VTC
se casse la jambe qui peut pas
travailler pendant 6 mois il va pas
revenir en tant que chauffeur de VTC
donc il y a besoin de protection sociale
simplement du bon sens et ça c'est un
des arbitrages que j'ai pu gagner
puisque uber France a été un des
premiers uber dans le monde à faire un
partenariat avec une assurance pour que
tous les chauffeurs qui roulent sur uber
soit assuré moi c'était juste une
évidence et je m'aime je vais dire tout
à la vérité lors de deux mois chez uber
il y avait une sorte de un boarding
comme on dit en anglais c'était donc on
vous fait rentrer dans l'entreprise donc
je pars à losange San Francisco pour la
über City c'était le nom que ça expliqué
et là comme c'était encore les débuts on
n'était pas tant que ça dans le monde on
avait encore un contact direct avec
trace qu'elle annonique à ce moment-là
dans ce moment-là et on arrive à la fin
d'une séance de questions-réponses avec
lui et je m'interroge sur la question de
la fiscalité et je lui dis excusez-moi
mais au niveau des impôts on roule sur
des routes les routes sont conçues par
les États s'il y a pas de route il y a
pas de business donc il est normal de
contribuer un minimum aux impôts et
c'est pas parce que l'optimisation
fiscale est légale qu'elle est logique
et rationnelle y compris au niveau
business et là il m'a répondu que
j'étais très français c'était très
français comme remarque il comprend en
parler autour d'une bouteille de vin
mais c'est des choses qui on avait le
droit de dire ça dans cette entreprise
et quand je dis ça ils m'ont pas viré et
quand ils m'ont recruté dans près de
recrutement moi ça faisait déjà des
années que j'étais sur Twitter et
j'avais fait des tweets d'analyses de la
situation de choses qui m'avait
interpellé sur uber ils l'ont fait en
connaissance de cause donc c'est une
entreprise on a le droit de débattre
droit de discuter et c'était un bras de
fer quasi permanent ce qui fait que
c'était aussi assez épuisant mais
c'était extrêmement intéressant donc
c'est une organisation qui est très
particulière et ça on peut pas s'en
rendre compte si on l'a pas vécu et ça
correspond pas aux modèles qui sont ceux
que vous pouvez connaître
une dernière question pour rebondir
toujours là-dessus donc vous avez parlé
du fait que les mangers du beurre de
l'époque sont très déçus des différents
dispositions qui sont prises et des
décisions qui sont prises dans la
période qui étudiées dans les liberfalls
et alors je voudrais vous poser un peu
la question symétrique en fait en
interne vous vous voyez d'une certaine
façon comme un garde-fou un modérateur
des opérationnels on a fait un public en
communication on pourrait essayer de
faire cadrer un peu plus leur leurs
actions éviter des faux pas je peux pas
mettre des douches mais je crois que
c'est comme ça en tout cas que je
comprends ce que la façon de faire
publique enfin en communication
est-ce que vous avez le sentiment à ce
moment en 2017 que c'est plutôt
l'approche des opérationnels
j'imagine celle d'un rapport de force un
peu brutal peut-être parfois à la limite
de la légalité comme on voit
l'utilisation du burpe tel que révélée
par Les ufils ou plutôt l'approche que
vous vous avez essayé de mettre en avant
l'approche qui est peut-être pour citer
les travesti plus française qui a pu
l'emporter après dans la façon dont
über assez comporter vis-à-vis des
autorités
pour moi
uber a sous la pression des États-Unis
en termes d'affaires publiques mes
collègues étaient toujours dans une
logique d'aller plus à la confrontation
même si essayait alors niveau il
faudrait les interroger d'ailleurs c'est
un peu surpris que vous m'appeliez moi
ici et pas eux mais pourquoi est-ce que
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que
nous et la ligne qu'on peut avoir qui
était peut-être plus modérée une
compréhension plus fine des conséquences
sociétales de ce qui se passait était
pas ce qui était mis en avant au niveau
de l'entreprise et que le retour de
bâton a été direct quand vous avez un
président de la République François
Hollande un premier ministre
même deux à la suite un millier de
transport qui sont absolument pas sur
cette ligne que les lois sont prises
avec deux rapporteurs qui font le
travail mais qui au final on parle au
sens que vous voulez c'est pas quelque
chose qui est positivement et en interne
c'était vécu comme une vraie
incompréhension les salariés du beurre
et tous les opérationnels qui se
battaient au quotidien parce qu'ils
pensaient vraiment à quelque chose
d'utile parce que le point de vue était
un point de vue des consommateurs des
passagers comprenaient pas et donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'en gros les
politiques nous font ça et pourquoi
est-ce que ils arrivent pas à comprendre
qu'on en train de faire quelque chose
qui aide déjà à travailler qui aident
des jeunes à se déplacer et qui a qui
fait sens parce qu'il y a pas de
conception politique en fait dans la
plupart de mes collègues c'est vraiment
très concrets
merci monsieur le Président
bonjour
monsieur Grégoire COP et chers collègues
moi je voudrais revenir d'abord sur
votre recrutement par Hubert on sait que
dans la stratégie du Berre et pour
cuber dans les différents pays du monde
puisse imposer son état de fait à l'état
droit
assumer revendiquait d'essayer de
débaucher des décideurs publics ou des
acteurs proches des décideurs publics
ils ont ainsi recruté par exemple Nily
Cruz ex-commissaire européenne en charge
de la concurrence qui par ailleurs avait
plaidé pour un dialogue social
des plateformes et des États membres
contre des droits sociaux elle avait
même fait des documents ce sens là pour
inciter les pays de l'Union membre de
l'Union européenne de procéder ainsi on
avait retrouvé cela dans un amendement
d'ailleurs carège de welkomery
Hubert avait recruté David plouf
ex-colaborateur
du président Obama et donc forcément
c'est difficile pour nous de voir
autrement que sous cet angle votre
recrutement et puis en même temps il y a
aussi les hasards de la vie moi je
voudrais vous lire
un des documents transmis par le lanceur
d'alerte Marc Magan il s'agit d'un mail
de Thomas je prononcerai très mal Thomas
Meester mais je sais pas si c'est comme
ça qu'on dit bon de thomaster qui dit la
chose suivante en date de février 2015
j'ai donc déjeuné avec Grégoire
conseiller à la communication d'un
avidaïs au secrétariat d'État aux
Transports Grégoire a fait partie de mon
équipe chez TBWA et fondateur du réseau
alsacien de Paris deux raisons de
l'estimer en un mot toute la sphère
institutionnelle et perplexe au sujet du
Berre en particulier et de l'industrie
du VTC en général autant au transport
qu'à l'intérieur personne est armé pour
comprendre les enjeux et défis posés par
la mobilité un point que manifestement
nous ne nous imaginons même pas le sujet
de plus considéré comme politiquement
minet avec que des coups à prendre
l'illusion taxi égale prescription
d'opinion reste bien ancrée tout le
monde s'est bien par ailleurs que la loi
TV nous est une mauvaise loi
inapplicable en l'état et dépassé de
toute part par la pratique d'où
l'embarras et la bataille chaude
l'intérieur ne veut pas se saisir du
sujet les transports ne savent pas par
où le prendre ça ne va nulle part
Grégoire va insister auprès du ministre
pour qu'il se saisisse du sujet d'abord
qu'il nous reçoivent de manière
informelle en Suisse dans ce cas-là la
priorité sera de répondre à toutes les
questions de droit du travail posé par
uber puisque c'est la spécialité du
ministre le touplet pour qu'après le
jugement du 23 nous sortions du bois
avec un push un temps soit peu agressif
ne serait-ce que pour prendre date et
manifester notre existence quelle
réaction vous pouvez avoir à
ce mail et est-ce que vous pensez à
posteriori que vous avez été
recruté parce que à un moment donné pas
simplement par les liens qui faisaient
que que monsieur
thomasmeester avait pu vous connaître
auparavant mais par le fait que vous
étiez membre du cabinet de visalys
est-ce que c'était pour renforcer leurs
moyens de lobbying au sein de l'appareil
d'État ou votre connaissance interne de
l'appareil d'État sachant que vous avez
précisé que le secteur communication
était assez différent d'un dissocier du
secteur affaire public alors que bon la
stratégie du Berre dans les affaires
publiques c'était quand même bien de
prendre des personnes qui en étaient qui
étaient issues l'appareil d'État
je vous remercie c'est assez flatteur
pour moi qu'on compariez à David plof ou
Nelly Croze mais moi je suis un avocat
un avocat devenu communicant qui a pris
trois ans de ma vie pour m'engager
lorsque un gouvernement socialiste est
revenu au pouvoir pour la première fois
depuis 1980 avec un président socialiste
donc je considère ça je ne suis pas une
personnalité politique je suis une
personne normale qui est passée avec
Thomas on se connaissait ce qui a été
écrit là correspond en plus à ce qui
s'est passé c'est à dire que finalement
c'était logique le secteur de taxi des
VTC sera patriothèse transport ce qui
était pas à l'époque
à ma connaissance il y a pas eu de
rendez-vous qui a été organisé donc
lui-même était déjà dans cette pression
de devoir avoir des résultats
comprenez que dans ce dans ce mail que
je vous lis
la suite de votre déjeuner avec Thomas
mystère fait que Thomas Meester peut
affirmer que vous allez insister auprès
du ministre et à cette époque là vous
travaillez avec le avec vidaliste vous
n'êtes pas encore recruté chez Hubert
donc vous êtes à ce moment-là pour
Thomas mystère celui qui va pouvoir
peser sur sur le ministre
Alain vidaliste de l'époque je pense que
c'était une tâche impossible par
ailleurs connaissant les convictions de
Monsieur vidaliste je voudrais par
ailleurs porter à votre connaissance
d'autres documents là c'est plus pour
réagir sur le fait que selon vous les
dirigeants du maire étaient très déçus
finalement que leur lobbying ne marche
pas alors première chose j'ai trouvé
très intéressant cette phrase lorsqu'on
a auditionné transparentie
internationale qui estiment que on
évalue pas
le lobbying
à l'aune de ces résultats d'un point de
vue de l'éthique politique pas d'un
point de fin d'un point de vue de
l'éthique politique les parlementaires
que nous sommes nous devons analyser
l'impact du lobbying pas simplement à
l'aune de leurs résultats mais comment
est-ce qu'on doit renforcer
l'encadrement du lobbying même quand il
est chou parce qu'il peut poser de
graves problèmes à la démocratie même
quand il est chaud alors il est vrai que
la loi est venu est grand Guillaume ne
vont pas du tout dans le sens du Berre
mais il est vrai aussi que la loi de
thévenus est grande Guillaume ne seront
pas appliqués et ne sont toujours pas
appliqués aujourd'hui il y a pas de
retour au garage il y a pas de
l'application l'interdiction de la
maraude électronique y compris la data
et on voit toutes les limites bon mais
j'ai un document là même trois documents
qui montrent que sur la négociation du
Berre
avec le ministre de l'économie de
l'époque Emmanuel Macron pour peser sur
la formation ils étaient ravis je vous
lis la chose suivante
bonsoir à tous Alors ça c'est un
document qui est qui date du 11 janvier
2016 et c'est Alexandre quintarcaigre
qui écrit visiblement à l'équipe de
dirigeants du maire bonsoir à tous nous
venons d'obtenir communication de
l'arrêté examen à première lecture s'est
arrêté va exactement dans le sens que
nous poussons depuis plusieurs mois il
reste quelques incohérences dans le
texte dont on sent qu'il a fait du coup
l'objet de l'autre négociation entre
ministère en terme de next steps
j'organise demain à 12h en Lisbonne une
séance de relecture de l'arrêté je
compte pour faire converger nos
compréhensions du texte et finaliser nos
positions je compte sur vous et votre
participation je vais partir du je vais
pas repartir au feu demain après-midi
pour faire bouger les derniers curseurs
les arbitrages ayant été rendus nous
n'avons que jusqu'à demain soir pour
faire part de nos derniers commentaires
je considère ce soir que ce texte est
une très forte avancée pour nous tous
même si ce n'est pas encore un régime
particulier j'entends déjà le
commentaire ton service blanc c'est une
blague entre vous c'est à dire qu'au
moment où uberpop s’arrête Hubert a
besoin absolument de beaucoup de
chauffeurs parce que sinon il y a pas
assez de chauffeur la clientèle n'est
pas satisfaite et là c'est la
catastrophe et donc il leur faut une
formation clé en main très rapidement on
va passer 250 à 7 heures et c'est ce
qu'ils obtiennent et ils sont ravis et
j'ai deux autres messages plus lourds
plus courts ou là si je les lis ça va
permettre de faire rire tous ceux qui
nous regardent tellement mon accent en
anglais catastrophique
je devrais plutôt te le faire lire voilà
que ce soit le président qui maîtrise
très bien cette langue wow this is même
si le chiffrement on ne va pas faire la
fine bouche Weldon Alex well don team
for the reasons the persistance the
super hardwork depuis plusieurs mois
depuis un an et demi tu veux dire
première rencontre Travis calanic Macron
septembre 2014 mais clairement depuis on
a pesé très lourd
now we need to bring this to the finish
line and the gouvernement Trave a
of courage
et là vous avez Marc Magan qui écrit à
Emmanuel Lacresse que je souhaiterais
qu'on auditionne mais le bureau ce matin
à voter contre toute nouvelle audition
et le président refuse à ce qu'on
auditionne les membres du cabinet
d'Emmanuel Macron de l'époque chère
Emmanuel ayant le plaisir de m'adresser
à un français je crois que les usages
m'autorisent à encore vous souhaiter une
très bonne année 2016 bien qu'elle soit
déjà entamée je m'adresse à vous sur le
projet permet d'arrêter relatif à la
formation et à l'examen des chauffeurs
VTC dont je me félicite surtout de
l'existence cela représente énormément
de travail de tous les côtés y compris
et surtout de la part du ministre de
l'économie du ministère de l'Économie et
nous en sommes sincèrement
reconnaissants ils ont gagné une
victoire ils se le disent entre eux et
j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils sont en
train d'exagérer comme vous l'avez
laissé entendre et qu'ils ventent ces
victoires là et qui seraient déçus par
ailleurs ils s'écrivent entre eux et ils
sont fiers de ces victoires là parce que
d'ailleurs ça va leur permettre de
recruter en masse et les taxis seront
vents debouts contre justement cet
arrêté sur la formation
je comprends que vous percevez ça comme
ça mais chez uber il y avait une valeur
principielle ces mots un peu bizarre qui
était d'être Super Pump c'est même le
nom du film qui est sur uber Super Pump
c'est quoi c'est super excité super
motivé je peux vous dire que les
Américains ce qu'ils voulaient c'était
le retour au régime de base ils arrivent
en France c'est génial on a un régime du
VTC ou c'est disponible d'avoir une
licence il faut avoir je crois que
c'était 18 ans un permis de conduire et
3 ans d'ancienneté et on pouvait avoir
une séance de VTC sans aucune condition
c'est ça qu'ils ont vu les Américains
donc toute contrainte qui s'achève
c'était pas une victoire là vous avez un
salarié qui vende son travail dans un
regardez ce que je fais c'est vachement
bien on peut pas lui en vouloir et elle
manager du salarié qui dit oui vas-y
c'est bien continue de cravacher mais
quand on prend ce que vous avez lu il y
a plein de moments où on voit qu'ils
étaient pas si content que ça et une
petite remarque également sur c'est
compliqué über parce que ça a beaucoup
évolué mais
uberpop uber x uber
uber pop pourquoi ça a été lancé parce
qu'aux États-Unis uber que départ est un
service de chauffeur privé un peu de
luxe a été lui-même disrupté il y a
toujours plus disrupteur que le
distributeur par lift juste a fait du
particulier aux particuliers donc là les
Américains se disent ah mais en fait il
y a deux modèles il y a des pays où il y
a des licences on fera des licences et
puis on va essayer un modèle sans
licence de particulier à particulier et
c'est quoi la première licorne française
comment elle s'appelle la plus grande
start-up c'est blablacar ils font quoi
blablacar ah du particulier à
particulier des Américains et c'est
génial la France vous avez une licorne
il fait du particulier à particulier
c'est donc légal est possible dans votre
pays et d'où le lancement du burpe en
disant si il y a une start-up française
qui le fait et qui se lance dans le
monde entier on peut le faire aussi chez
vous sauf que blablacar je suis d'accord
ça correspond plutôt à du stop
digitalisé que le VTC c'est quelque
chose de payant donc c'est pas la même
chose mais philosophiquement ce que vont
à quoi vont réfléchir comment
réfléchissent les Américains sur ces
sujets c'est que si vous avez le droit
d'aller dans un blablacar aujourd'hui
quel est le contrôle d'un chauffeur
est-ce qu'on l'a fait passer un examen
est-ce qu'on a vérifié pourtant il va
vous prendre vous votre fille vous
emmener de Paris à vos vacances à
Bordeaux pendant 7 heures sur la
nationale sur l'autoroute on sait pas
qui c'est on n'a pas son permis on n'a
pas de contrôle il est pas formé et
c'est pas grave ça marche très bien le
locataire c'est une licorne et j'adore
blablacar et j'en souhaite tout le
bonheur du monde et c'est ça qui se
disent les Américains c'est hyper
incohérent c'est
écoutez je crois qu'on a fait le tour
des questions je vous interrogerai pas
sur vos choix d'employeurs
footballistique plus contestables mais
je vous remercie monsieur Coop de votre
disponibilité de vos réponses à nos
questions et puis aussi d'ailleurs de la
transmission exhaustive de documents en
amont de cette audition qui a pu nous
permettre de la de la préparer nous ont
peut-être d'ailleurs des questions
complémentaires ou des documents mais
dans l'intervalle je vous souhaite une
excellente journée